the critics have spoken and they do not
like Suicide Squad love your perfume
what is that the scent of death but
audiences showed up anyway proving once
again that franchise tentpoles do not
necessarily live and die by the critical
reception that doesn't mean moviegoers
loved everything they saw though as
Jared Leto puts in his bid to appear and
Ben Affleck standalone Batman flick
let's take a look at what fans think of
Jared Leto's Joker laughable behavior
the story of letõs onset antics made
headlines before suicide squads debut
he's a method actor so he isolated
himself from the rest of the cast
servicing only to send his co-stars
bizarre gifts I can't wait to show you
much boys when it comes to rats bullets
and dead hogs amongst other things he's
apparently very generous he's behind the
scenes behavior generated a lot of hype
around his seemingly zany performance
making it a point of major curiosity
especially since Leto is known to be
very selective about his acting gigs
however many were underwhelmed by his
performance and one consistent complaint
has been that letõs betrayal was too
over the top the Joker is classically a
wild card but after Jack Nicholson's
work in Tim Burton's Batman and the
legendary interpretation that Heath
Ledger offered in Christopher Nolan's
The Dark Knight
letõs work was almost exasperated for
those that didn't like it long walk for
a short joke another common complaint
even from those who didn't love letõs
part in the movie is that he didn't get
enough face time in the flick letter who
said that many of his scenes were left
on the editing room floor which seems
accurate since he's barely in the movie
despite being such a central part of the
film's promotion or campaign some fans
said they saw more of him in his music
video appearance than the movie
itself which was disappointing although
not exactly his fault twitter titters
not everyone dislikes Leto's Joker a
quick glimpse at social media reveals
plenty of fans who enjoyed his unique
energy and who were happy to see a new
take on the character an unexpected
thread amongst fans of bladders Joker
that he was too damn sexy in the role
the some film goers letter remains a
handsome man and no amount of grills or
wacky tattoos can take that away creepy
cutter another notch in the plus column
for letter as Joker the fact that he was
at times pretty chilling to watch
considering he wasn't even the main
villain he still managed a freak
audiences out making good use of his
limited screen time the last laugh Leto
hasn't yet reached icon status as the
Joker in Suicide Squad thanks to his
brief screen time and the mixed fans
reaction to his work in the role but it
wasn't a total wash either given a
little more time and material letter
could have still gone down as one of
fans favorite Joker's in cinematic
history this movie didn't do that for
him so maybe a turn as the resident
supervillain and Affleck standalone
feature is in order after all thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what you thought of Jared
Leto's Joker